مراسلنا ايهاب العقده ايهاب حدثنا اكثر
وقربنا مما
[موسيقى]
جرى طبعا بلده عيتا الشعب وقعت فيها غاره
قبل بعض الوقت هذه الصور التي تشاهدونها
هي للحظه تشييع احد مقاتلي حزب الله الذي
كان نعهم حزب الله يوم امس في غاره
اسرائيليه على احد المنازل التي كانوا
يتحصنون بها هذه الغاره لم تسفر حتى الان
عن سقوط اي شهداء في الجانب اللبناني لكن
هناك بعض الاصابات الطفيفه من جراء تطاير
الحجاره والشظايا
باتجاه
المشيعين اليوم حزب الله كان كان دعا الى
تشييع احد شهدائه في هذه البلده بمشاركه
المئات من ابناء البلده والبلدات المحيطه
بها بلده عيتا شعب هي بلده محاذ للحدود
تماما في القطاع الاوسط وهي تضم مئات ال
العائلات التي لازالت تسكن بها وايضا
الجانب الاسرائيلي كان يستهدف اطرافها
باستمرار بالقذائف والغارات منذ اندلاع
المواجهات في جنوب لبنان حزب الله ايضا
كان شن سلسله من العمليات باتجاه المواقع
المختلفه القريبه من هذه البلده لكن
الواضح ان هذا التصعيد هو تصعيد خطير من
الجانب الاسرائيلي خصوصا وان هذه الغاره
لو اصابت او لو انحرفت قليلا عن الهدف
الذي اصابته في هذا المبنى القريب منها
لكانت ادت الى مجزره حقيقيه في فيما بين
المشيعين الذين حضروا الى ساحه البلده
التي كانت تقام بها مراسم التشييع حزب
الله عمليا كان خلال الفترات الاخيره
يختصر اوقات التشييع في مناطق مختلفه من
جنوب لبنان اثناء تشييع مقاتليه لكنه يحرص
على وقف اي عمليات في القرى التي يجري
التشييع بها وبالتالي لا يقوم باي عمليات
هجوميه من المناطق التي تقام بها مراسم
التشييع لمقاتليه اي هذه المنطقه ايضا هي
تقع قباله ال او في القطاع الاوسط
اللبناني قباله عدد من المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل حاله
الت بالقسوه في تلك المنطقه ويقصف
باستمرار بالمدفعيه وايضا بالرشاشات كل
المنطقه المحيطه بعيت الشعب عيت الشعب في
عام 2006 شهدت احدى اعتى المواجهات
العسكريه بين حزب الله والجيش الاسرائيلي
وتعد ايضا بوابه رئيسيه للجنوب اللبناني